en irak le meurtre d'un expert en
sécurité spécialiste des mouvements
terroristes
hicham al hachémi tué devant son
domicile c'était ce lundi ciel un homme
engagé dans la révolte populaire qui
dénonçait notamment l'ingérence de
l'iran et des états unis dans son pays
vivement critiquée dans l'opinion
publique le premier ministre moustapha
kazemi a promis de retrouver les auteurs
du crime
un meurtre qui vit craint des
affrontements entre chiites et
nationaliste écoutez les analyse un
expert en sécurité et d'un politologue
je pense qu'il s'agit d'un message pour
monsieur moustapha a quasi me et que
cela n'a rien à voir avec la liberté
d'expression
l'opinion publique l'idéologie le
journalisme ou les médias
c'est un message politique fort pas une
protestation contre l'absence de liberté
d'expression
bien sûr que cela va affecter la
sécurité intérieure du pays sans
véritable test pour le gouvernement de
mustapha al-qasimi et quant aux partis
politiques s'accusent mutuellement